so wirkmen im Camper wir haben im ersten
Teil von der camperie schon richtig viel
gemacht wir haben jetzt hier die
Verkleidung wir haben hier Bänke alles
möglich wir haben die Küche angefangen
wir haben super viele Sachen gemacht
damit jetzt in diesem Teil endlich die
Sachen passieren können die richtig geil
sind und richtig Spaß machen noch mal
ein kleiner Rückblick der Camper soll
später so aussehen ja also mit richtig
geilen Materialien Betonoptik hier
schönestichen geile Kissen das soll
richtig wild aussehen da soll nürlich
auch alles möglich haben Dusche
Warmwasser Küche mit Herd und Spüle und
alle möglichen S auch ein Solarpanel
aufs Dach viele von euch haben es in
Kommentaren geschrieben das machen wir
auch und mit das geilste Feature das
machen wir jetzt direkt jetzt hier am
Anfang und zwar ein höhenverstellbares
Bett das hier rein soll soll man nach
oben fahren können soll dann einfach die
Decke bilden wenn man hier so sitzt und
einfach keinen Platz wegnehmen und wenn
man es dann braucht kann man hier drauf
schlafen und hier unten sogar noch ein
Gästebett haben das wird geil und das
braen wir
[Musik]
jetzt so das alles hier soll auf jeden
Fall reichen fürs Bett wir haben un ein
bisschen Plan gemacht wie wir das genau
machen aber wir können jetzt auch
unkompliziert ohne CD tatsächlich ich
Dach mir gerade ich glaub zum
allerersten Mal ohne CD Konstruktion
bauen wir jetzt einfal was unsere
Matratze soll 2 m X 1/ vi sein also ist
richtig also ist echt riesig eigentlich
für ein Camper würde ich sagen also
nicht richiesig aber ist schon schon
schon okay kann man sich nicht
beschweren also so hält nürlich das
Brett auch nichts aus muss man zugeben
aber später wird ja so stehen und da ist
auf jeden Fall komplett stabil da geht
gar nichts inind 18 cm und das Segen wir
jetzt mal in der Mitte
durch und haben wir
143,6 also ganz genau hier
also diese vier Bretter so wie sie jetzt
da stehen m ir verbinden und zwar so und
jetzt relativ unkompliziert würde ich
ein Winkel reinmachen wen wir dafür die
das sind nicht die einzigen Winkel
reinkommen weil die würden das nicht
unbedingt halten aber auch die kommen
rein später werden auch mit der Post
welche anderen geliefert aber erst
machen wir die da rein so schauen wir
mal
[Musik]
fest man spürt gar kein Widerstand ne W
jetzt bisschen winkeleskapade weil glaub
nicht dass diese drei Schrauben
großseitig was halten ich willlich auch
nicht jetzt einf solche Winkel nehmen
weil die sind halt jetzt nicht hübsch
und man sieht später von unten drum wir
kombinieren jetzt ein bisschen was dafür
müssen wir allerdings diese Winkel hier
noch mal ein bisschen custom
[Musik]
zuflexen h sind jetzt oben also die
abgeflexten Winkel dran unten die
schönen Winkel die man später sehen wird
das wird man später nicht sehen das Ding
ist halt komplett gebogen also Holz ist
halt bisschen Naturprodukt ist Hal nicht
wirklich was gerade so er kommt hier
rein so weil es natürlich jetzt noch so
nach gar nichts hält ne also wenn man
das jetzt so auseinander spreizen würde
wird das sich verbiegen bisum geht nicht
mir haben jetzt hier noch mal ein
schönes edelstahlding das kann man auch
speder sehen das kommt dann so rein die
Höhe habe ich mir gerade hier angesägt
das heißt ich kann das jetzt einach
runterlegen kann das hier dann
drauflegen und hat das die perfekte Höhe
weil wir brauchen unten her noch Platz
für Mechanismus das bet nach oben und
unten heben wird
später so der Rahmen vom Bett ist jetzt
erstmal fertig jetzt muss natürlich
irgendwo auch später die Matratze
drauflegen und das ist auf dem
Lattenrost und die Ben wir jetzt hier
selber ma geschneidert und der
Lattenrost muss auch wieder rum auf
irgendwas drauf liegen und das ist diese
Leiste hier und die schraube ich jetzt
hier dran und dafür braucht man
schrauben jo liegt die Hälfte wieder am
Boden rum ach so der schon
vorbereitet perfekt jetzt andere Seite
und die ist
hier so wir richten unsere
Aufmerksamkeit mal hier drauf also ihr
seht jetzt dass diese Leiste hier drauf
ist aber nicht bis ganz na hinten hier
fehlt nämlich ein Stück und das hat auch
ein guten Grund da kommt nämlich der
Mechanismus hin der später das ganze
Ding zu also das ganze Bett zum hoch und
runterfahren bringen wird da kommt so
ein Motor rein und diese Welle also
diese dieses Rohr quasi und deshalb
kommt er jetzt hier rein und er begrenzt
noch mal quasi den Raum wo diese dieses
Drehmechanismus Zeug ist und das wird
auch noch später verkleidet dass man
davon nichts mehr sieht fehlt jetzt noch
das Lattenrost dann haben wir eigentlich
schon richtiges Bett dann kommt no eine
ganze Mechanismus aber erstmal ist
Lattenrost dafür brauchen wir die Latten
die 3 m Latten müssen alle auf 140
zugeschnitten werden let's
go
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und das Teil tragen wir jetzt erstmal in
den Camper um zu schauen ob es überhaupt
[Musik]
reinpasst gut let's go warte kurz
abstellen es geht sogar so flach ja geil
passt voll gut damit man dem Kämpfer auf
nichts verzichten muss kommt da genau
wie seit über zwei auch in unserem
Schlafzimmer eine Emma Matratze rein und
das eliteflauschkissen von Emma die das
heutige Video auch unterstützen
Alter oh das ist unnormal ihr kennt dass
der self wen das Kissen umdreht und das
dann wieder so geil kühl ist hier legt
man einfach immer auf der kühlen Seite
weil durch die airgrid Oberfläche die
warme Luft aus dem Kissen entweicht
damit kann man besser schlafen hat eine
längere tiefschlaffphase und ist morgens
fit das in der Höhe anpassbare
Innenkissen mit atmungsaktiver Füllung
ist nicht nur ultra bequem sondern
unterstützt auch den Kopf die Schultern
und Nacken wir wollten das Bett so dünn
wie möglich halten damit wir im Camper
möglichst viel Platz haben wenn das Bett
an der Decke ist aber für den
ultimativen Schlafkomfort gibt's noch
den 9 cm hohen mremma Premium Topper der
sorgt zu jeder Jahreszeit fürs perfekte
Schlafklima wodurch man in der Nacht
nicht mehr schwitzt das Kissen und den
Topper die übrigens gerade um 50%
reduziert sind sowie alles rund ums
Thema Schlaf findet ihr im Emma
onlineineshop klick dazu auf den Link in
der Videobeschreibung und sichert euch
bei den Black weeks die bei Emma ab
jetzt bis zum 30.11 laufen bis zu 50%
Rabatt und mit meinem Code Tom van noch
mal 5% oben drauf und jetzt Bett
reinpasst müssen uns noch überlegen wie
wir das hoch und runter gefahren kriegen
und jetzt wir der hier läuft B den auch
schon direkt ein das ist ein ziemlich
wildes Konzept umig zu sein so in eine
Ecke kommt jetzt der Motor und das wird
die untere Ecke sein also angefangen mit
dem Motor wird in soem Ding hier drin
befestigt sieht so aus dann kommt da
dieses achteckige Ding drauf der Motor
bringt das dann zum Drehen S auf der
anderen Seite sollte eigentlich das Teil
hier reingehen also das ist ir so ein
bisschen verdellt und ja auf jeden muss
jetzt irgendwie dafür sorgen dass das
Teil hier diese den nicht meh hat diese
Spitzen also ich habe das jetzt ein
wieder ein bisschen flach gedrückt mit
der Zange hier und jetzt werde ich mit
dem Hammer das einmal hier duufhauen und
hoffen dass ich das alles entspannt
verbiegt ohne dass irgendwas kaputt geht
okay womöglich kam mir gerade nicht so
eine gute Idee da drauf zu haauen auf
dem Motor jetzt das Teil abgenommen hab
das dann quasi hier reingelegt hab dann
D Hammer drauf drin war dann mit dem
Holzstück das noch tiefer gemacht hab
einmal komplett durchgejagt und jetzt
soll es eigentlich hier mit dem Motor
durchgehen ja es geh im noch streng aber
ist okay so könen wir den jetzt ins Bett
reinbauen hier und hier okay aber wir
sich das ganze jetzt drehen
[Musik]
ja diese Seilwinde hier die soll ja
später mal genau das machen was der Name
sagt und zwar Seilwinden das wird
aufgespult muss aber irgendwie natürlich
noch nach oben an die Decke gelenkt
werden und das passiert mit in der
Umlenkrolle und die Schrauben wir jetzt
[Applaus]
ran okay die Schnur hier wird später
hier befestigt wird dann aufgewickelt
geht über diese Rolle geht über diese
zweite Rolle und wird dann hier eben
geführt und hier ist das Ende was an der
Decke befestigt wird das funktioniert so
das funktioniert genauso die da
funktioniert bisschen anders dafür
brauchen wir auf jeden Fall trotzdem
diese Rolle muss Schnur aufwickeln und
die Schnur muss hier so rüber gehen und
deswegen machen wir jetzt hier kurz mal
ein kleinen Kanal in das Holz rein damit
das
durchkommt
ich Fed gerade jetzt die Schnur durch
damit ich die festknoten kann ich habe
jetzt no mal hier bisschen Schutz drüber
gemacht damit das Seil noch bisschen
stabiler wird und irgendwie nicht hier
da dran abgeschnitten wird nur jetzt ein
paar mal drum rum gewickelt s jetzt
hoffentlich stabil genug dran geht dann
hier komplett einmal rüber auf die ganz
andere Seite da habe ich jetzt gerade
schon diese Rolle da befestigt und da
musst jetzt irgendwie D dururch um quasi
von der Unterseite vom Bett zack nach
oben zu kommen genau hier wird die
Matratze später liegen und da soll jetzt
quasi durch das Loch das ich gerade
schon gebut die Schnur durch damit das
hier nicht aufwetzt an dem Holz und
nicht an der Matratze irgendwie die
Matratze aufsägt nach einer Zeit kommt
jetzt gleich so ein plastikchlauch rein
und zack das Schlauch kommt da durch
jetzt kommt er hier rein er hier ist so
eine rohrklemme oder so und da fehle ich
jetzt die Schnur
durch wir sind zurück im Camper das Bett
ist nämlich jetzt erstmal fertig jetzt
müssen wir noch die Aufhängungen für die
Schnüre machen die müssen irgendwie an
die Decke befestigt werden und weil ich
glaube dass stabiler ist als es einfach
so ans Holz dran zu machen und weil die
natürlich auch noch eine andere Funktion
haben zu der wir aber später erst kommen
kommt dafür hier so eine Aluleiste ran
und die Schrauben wir jetzt in jeder
Ecke mal fest okay es haben sich jetzt
einige sidequs aufgetan und zwar wie
folgt also die Mission ist ja dass wir
ein vier Ecken also hier hier und hier
und aber auch hier diese Aluleisten
haben von unten nach oben an denen sich
quasi das Bett dann hochziehen kann und
auch etappenweise so mit so einem Riegel
halt befestigt werden kann aber bevor
die jetzt ir an diese Wand dranemacht
werden gibt noch ein paar andere Sachen
die man machen muss also diese Wände
gibt's teilweise noch gar nicht weil ne
hier und hier ist easy aber hier ist
Problem weil hier oben ist noch nichts
das kriegen wir irgendwie hin aber vor
allem ist hier hier diese Klappe und
wenn da eine Klappe ist kann da halt
schlecht so ein Aluprofil stehen ne also
das dann geht ja nicht mehr auf drum
müssen wir als erstes hier so ein Stück
abschneiden und das linke davon
befestigen und darauf dann dieses
Aluprofil drauf zu machen in dieser Ecke
ja da soll dieses Aluprofil eigentlich
an den Schrank rein aber der ist noch
nicht da also müssen wir beim Schrank
auch erstmal so eine Wand hochziehen an
die wir das befestigen können das heißt
es gibt erstmal eine side Quest
[Musik]
Montage
ich habe das jetzt an der Bandsäge
zugeschnitten und er passt jetzt hier
perfekt hier rein und den Schrauben wir
jetzt hier schon mal
fest so die Schraubenköpfe werden später
noch mal verspachtelt dann wird es
überstrichen ich glaube dann sieht ganz
geil
aus die Seite habe ich gestern nach der
no fertig gemacht finde ich super geil
wirkt schon mal richtig cozy hier also
voll gemütliche Ecke jetzt die side
Quest geht weiter denn wir müssen auch
noch die Seite hier fertig machen da
muss auch noch die Wand dran und bevor
ich das machen kann muss ich noch mal
quasi diese beiden Wände hier
miteinander verbinden dafür habe ich
jetzt gerade diese Dinger zugesägt und
auch zugegmaßen sehr riskant gebohrt
aber funktioniert und damit ziehe ich
die jetzt
rein so die Wand hier habe ich schon mal
zugeschnitten die passt auch perfekt
rein und die schauen wir jetzt
fest
okay und
damit passt wie angegossen ist die war
fertig ich muss noch kurz festschrauben
nachdem jetzt ab wirklich auch jede
einzelne side Quest erledigt wurde es
hat echt zwei Tage gedauert ne wir haben
gestern angefangen hat zwei Tage
gedauert bis die sideite Quest gemacht
haben können wir jetzt auch die Leisten
einbauen die sind jetzt ja richtig
angezeichnet das ist richtig angelegt
und jetzt geht's da rein würde ich sagen
erste
[Musik]
Schraube ist echt ein gutes Gefühl kann
man nichts anderes sagen also wirk nach
zwei Tagen endlich die Dinger hier
versenken pas perfekt rein richtig geil
gut auf die andere
[Musik]
Seite so jetzt kommt auch dahin noch die
Leiste wir haben das hier vorh ein
bisschen abgeschnitten hier
abgeschrägt damit das jetzt noch in die
Ecke passt und ja das kommt jetzt ran ah
ja warte noch mal eine side Quest und da
ist noch verkleidungsstück irgendwo weil
das muss auch noch
dran so jetzt
[Musik]
aber sweet die Leisten sind alle fertig
alle vier die sieht man nicht aber jetzt
kommt
Bett also okay dann rein
danke ich glaub es passt
nicht okay also erstmal muss man positiv
sagen es ist cool dass es B hier drin
ist
ja das war es auch schon wenn das Bett
bis hier hin fährt dann wird es
wahrscheinlich einfach nicht reichen ne
ich habe eine Idee testen
etwas
so geil wird und zwar haben wir jetzt
diese Aluleisten die davor hier waren
einfach nach außen verschoben dadurch
konnte das ganze Bett noch mal ca 3 cm
weiter reingeschobben werden und hat
genug Platz Bett kriegt Strom ich habe
jetzt nämlich die Schnüre schon
befestigt an so Rollen sieht geil aus
alle Leisten sind drin mega nice wir
Test auf das Bett fliegen kann ja let's
go bin richtig gespannt okay oh ich habe
bisschen Angst dass es jetzt irgendwie
explodiert oder so keine Ahnung warum
mal schauen ob das
funktioniert es fliegt es AK bisschen
schräg weil der Bus schief steht oder
der Transporter aber es geht nach oben
oh das ist so geil das ist so
geil hier stopt es automatisch das
später noch dass es bisschen anders ist
übel geil okay machen mal
runter
e das
insane not bad so wir testen mal was die
Matratze zack so und auch mit Matratze
und geilem eliteflauschkissen zieht den
al jetzt hier gemächlich nach oben muss
noch einstellen dass der ganz in die
Decke geht und dafür verstelle ich hier
am Motor einfach so eine Schraube dann
sollst direkt noch ein Stück höher
fahren
jo genau und so ungefähr könnte dann
eine Endposition aussehen das ist noch
ein bisschen schief das muss hier später
noch ein bisschen höher D ma ich se
kürzer aber so ist es jetzt und jetzt
sitzt man hier hat oben halt gut Platz
man kann ja nicht mehr richtig stehen
man kann da vorne auf recht stehen und
hier gehst also ein bisschen gebückt
runter und sitzt du dann und hast auf
jeden Fall zum chillen und zum Sitzen
mehr als genug Platz ist richtig geil
mach noch mal runter und zeig euch mal
die Position auf der man ungefähr so
dieses gästebet Setting haben wird ja
vielleicht nicht ganz so aber noch ein
Stück noch mal so und das mag zwar eng
sein aber da oben hat man auf jeden Fall
richtig bequem und auch da drunter kann
man auch bequem schlafen und so wird
dann hier die Schnur aufgezogen richtig
cool dass das so gut funktioniert auch
ein wilder Mechanismus um zu sein bis
nach der ganz da drüben die Idee dafür
also auch mit dem rolladmotor haben wir
übrigens vom Youtuber wenig den ich euch
auch mal verlinkt
habe und dann hat man h eine richtig
bequeme Schlafecke das richtig richtig
geil auch das Fenster hinten mega nice
ich hab so Bock auf die erste Nacht und
den ersten Trip hier kämf das wird
glaube ich unnormal geil und eigentlich
könnte man jetzt auch schon matratz ist
da drin direkt ein ersten Trip machen
hier mein ganz weitwinkliger Blick vom
Camper hier von ganz hinten sieht man
dass man neben diesem Bett da hinten
halt noch mal so viel Platz hier vorne
hat für Dusche und nicen Schrank und Hal
die Küche eben und dann fehlt natürlich
jetzt noch einiges also generell Farbe
ne komplett auch das Bett wird
angestrichen hier wird alles
angestrichen oder tapeziert oder mit
Betonoptik verkleidet dann um das Bett
auf Zwischenstufen zu parken ja also
soll auch quasi hier auf halber Höhe mal
sein dass quasi unten Gäste schlafen
können oben man selbst schlafen kann wir
hier noch so Pins geben wo man das Bett
quasi ein was so einrasten lassen kann
weil nur auf den Seen würde ich gerade
nicht schlafen und klar kommt noch ein
Schrank hin die Küche wir noch ausgebaut
kriegt noch die tche mit warm Wasser und
so weit und so fort kommt noch ein
Solarpanel aufs Dach kriegt noch so ein
Kontrollzentrum alles mögliche das war's
auf jeden Fall mit diesem Teil des
campmferausbaus jetzt haben wir das Bett
hier oben gebaut und im nächsten Tag
geht's weiter wenn ihr das nicht
verpassen möchtet abonniert unbedingt
den Kanal den Link zur Emma Matratze und
den ganzen anderen schlafzer von Emma
findet ihr auch in der Videobeschreibung
und das war's damit von mir macht's gut